SPEAKER: OK, quiet.
I'll try and wake you up.
No, I won't.
I'm back to do a talk and sort
of demo of some of the tools
that we use for
building progressive web
apps, some things that you
can use to understand how
your apps work, and how
you can make your web
experiences better.
One thing I will say about
this demo before I go on,
I am gonna cheat a little bit
today and I will apologize.
I'm not going to do that
live because the internet
connection here is
a little bit slow
and for me to do this live,
it just wouldn't work.
So I took screenshots
and video last night,
so I'll show you
essentially what I would do.
But I want to take
you on a journey.
I want to take you through how
you can use some of these tools
to make your experience,
your site better.
As developers, it's
important for us
to have insight into
areas that we can improve
and areas that we can
make things work better
and make things more
awesome for our users.
So in that spirit, let's take
a little journey on a website
and transform an
existing single-page app,
from just a pretty
meh single-page app
to a progressive web app.
Our starting point
is this app here
that you'll see on the right.
And it uses the iFixit API.
iFixit is-- how many people
are familiar with iFixit?
OK, so a few.
iFixit is a site that they do
teardowns and take products
apart and show you how
to fix it yourself.
So it's a pretty neat site
in terms of some of the stuff
that they have, but
they also have an API so
that you can write
your own frontend.
This site in its
current implementation,
and what I'm going to
show you in one second,
uses client-side rendering.
So it goes, gets the data,
and renders on the client.
And it uses React to do this.
The concepts that I'm
going to talk about today,
you can use any framework.
In fact, I'm using React because
it was just an experiment.
I don't really
know React at all.
We're going to have people come
in and talk about it Angular.
These tests that I'm
gonna show you how to do,
the work that I'm
gonna show, applies
exactly the same, no matter
what browser you're using
or what library you're using.
I'm going to open it up and have
a look at what the experience
looks like in Chrome.
So, I'll open it up.
It looks like a
standard web app, right?
It's got a nice
little address bar
across the top, some
images, and I can
click on any of these things.
All right, Chrome looks great.
And Firefox, because it's
always important for us
to be testing our apps in
all of the different browsers
that our users are using.
So look at your analytics, what
browsers are users coming in on
and making sure that you're
testing on those browsers.
So Firefox, yep, looks great,
awesome, yay, really happy.
But Safari, I've made a
little bit of a change,
because I think it's
always important to test
in one browser where you've
turned off JavaScript.
And wah-wah, right?
That's bad.
It's not that Safari is bad.
We have turned off JavaScript
and we're client-side
rendering.
Client-side rendering plus
no JavaScript means no page.
So in this particular
instance, this sucks.
Our users who don't have
JavaScript are kind of stuck.
So now that we have a
feel for what the app does
and what it looks like,
let's try and figure
out how we can improve
this implementation
and we're going to use a
tool called Lighthouse.
Lighthouse is a tool that is
built by a number of engineers
in Google, and automates a
whole suite of diagnostic tests
that cover areas important
to progressive web apps.
It's available as
a Chrome extension,
so you can get it as
a Chrome extension.
And it's available as
a couple other things.
But first, let's use Lighthouse
to establish a baseline,
to see how it's going to work.
I meant to mention this earlier,
it also works as a Node module,
so you can test your
app as you're running.
You don't always have to use
it as a Chrome extension.
You can put this into
maybe your build process
to understand, hey,
how are things working?
And get your score there.
Before we jump in and see what
our Lighthouse score looks
like on this test,
Lighthouse is a process.
It is not a destination.
It's to help us identify
areas that we can improve,
but it's not the thing
that we're going to say,
I want to get a 100 out of 100.
It's kind of nice, but
that's not the point.
The point is for us to take
our step up from wherever
we are and build it better.
Ultimately the experience
that your web app provides
is for your entire
user community,
and that's what matters most,
is building a great experience.
In addition to testing across
all devices, like I said,
it's important to test across
different browsers and OSs.
You can't just use Lighthouse
and be like, woohoo!
Done.
Don't do that.
That's bad.
Test across all
devices and browsers,
and use different tools
to help you understand.
So with that, let's take
a look and see how we do.
Whoa.
20 out of 100.
Now, I said that getting 100
was not your goal, but 20 sucks.
We want a better number than 20.
So let's take a look at
why we have a score of 20.
First thing you'll
notice is it's
checking to see if there's
an offline experience,
so app can load in an
offline or flaky connections.
It's looking for
a service worker.
It's looking to see
that when it's offline,
that there's a 200 response.
There's two things that
we know we can fix today,
we've learned how to do that.
We can implement the service
worker and we can fix that one.
OK.
Good.
Performance is fast.
First meaningful paint, it
took almost four seconds
until the first meaningful
paint today, or for me
to run this last night.
That's a lot of time.
So we had to download
not only the HTML,
but then we had to
download the JavaScript, we
had to parse the JavaScript, we
had to execute the JavaScript,
and then we went, oh, right,
I guess I need some data.
So we went and got the data,
we downloaded the data,
and then we could
render something.
That's client-side rendering.
If we switch to
server-side rendering,
where we just make the
request and it's like, hey,
here's everything, that
number's going to come down.
Perceptual speed index,
OK, that's kind of high.
Time to interact, it was
almost just over seven seconds.
That's slow.
So I think we can
do a bunch of things
to improve our performance.
The next thing it's
going to look at
is the site is
progressively enhanced.
So there's one
key test for this.
Page contains some content
when scripts are not available.
We saw that.
Wah-wah, right?
That's another easy one
for us to fix by adding
some server-side rendering.
So no content when
JavaScript is unavailable.
Your network connection
is not secure,
or your network
connection is secure.
Remember, we talked earlier,
service workers require HTTPS.
Now, I'm running this
on my local machine,
so I don't really
need that right now,
so we're just going
to ignore that one.
That one's OK to fail when
you're doing local development.
Then the next thing its asks
is, the user can be prompted
to add to the home screen.
So it looks for a service
worker, a manifest,
the manifest contains
the start URL,
an icon is listed in the
manifest, and a short name.
So it looks for the things
that Chrome needs prompt.
Finally, installed web
app can be launched
from the splash screen.
So it's checking for a
bunch of things here.
This is another easy
one for us to fix.
Sam showed us earlier how
we can go add that manifest,
and we're gonna go
add a manifest today.
And then address bar
matches brand colors.
The design is mobile friendly,
well, it is mobile friendly.
So at least we got
that one going for us.
It checks for a number
of best practices,
looking for things
like offline futures,
looking for performance
with HTTP/2,
it looks for accessibility and
a number of things like that,
and finally the
performance metrics.
So it gives us a
lot of data for us
to be able to go, huh,
how's our site doing?
Is it any good?
The first thing
that I want to do
is go and add server-side
rendering to my app.
I want to take this app
that we've built already
and is doing all
client-side, and remember,
this is client-side with React.
So that means the browser
gets a fully populated page
in the initial HTTP response
when I do server-side rather
than relying on
multiple requests
to get content on the screen.
Equally important, it
means that our web app
will work in browsers
where JavaScript
is disabled, in
that Safari example
that I talked about earlier.
Now, not every web app will be
able to run with full fidelity
with JavaScript disabled,
but in our case that's OK.
Users are going to
click on something
and see something else.
It works.
So it's fairly straightforward
to add in server-side rendering
to our React app using
universal JavaScript
that we can share between
our client and our server.
So we're going to use Express
in Node as our web server,
because it plays nicely
with the React router.
While we're talking about
React, like I said earlier,
other frameworks,
like Angular, Ember,
have their own solutions
for server-side rendering.
So this works for them as well.
I'm just using this as the
specific example today.
So you can see here
I've added to a--
I've got a gulpfile as
part of my build process,
and I've added a
new gulp serve task,
which is going to
serve my app, it's
going to spin up
my Node web server.
And I've added a web
server to my build,
so this is where
we're actually going
to build the server rendered
version of the page.
And down here I've got
this really important bit.
This is where we're
actually going
to use React to render
the page on the server.
So now when I make a request
for that initial page,
I get the content
already rendered.
I need to make one
other change to my page.
I need to change my index.html
because I need to actually make
it templated so that I can
start to render the content
server-side.
And all I do is have this
fairly simple HTML body
and I've got React HTML
as my template in there.
So I'm just going to
shove everything in.
So now that we've got
server-side templating set up,
let's run the Lighthouse tests
again and confirm that it
worked, so see how it did.
And let's also have a
look at it in Safari
and see if it works there,
because it should work now.
So Chrome.
Starts loading.
Spin, spin, spin.
It's taking a
little bit of time.
There it works.
Notice how this time one of the
big differences was that images
started populating
in almost right away,
whereas last time all of
a sudden we saw the boxes
and then a few seconds
later we got the images.
So the perceived performance of
this was actually much faster.
It took a little bit of extra
time at the very beginning
to get that content
down, but as a user
I feel like it rendered faster.
Safari.
Let's see how this one goes.
Remember, this didn't
work at all last time.
And there we go.
So in Safari, now we
get all of our images.
It works.
It behaves as we would
expect it to work in Safari.
That's awesome.
We've got a little
bit of a step forward.
Let's run Lighthouse.
This is what Lighthouse
looks like when you run it.
I've got it up as the
Chrome extension up there,
so I just went and I
hit the button that
says, OK, it's going to go run.
And it does a bunch
of different things,
it requests the page
in debugging mode,
it requests the page in
different screen sizes,
it goes and runs and
requests Web SQL data,
it does all kinds
of crazy things.
Then it comes back and
it gives us this result.
We went from 22 to 37.
OK.
All right.
I'll take that.
Still not a passing
grade, but we've gone up.
Now there's a couple of
things that have happened
to make our experience better.
App can load in flaky-- we
didn't do anything around that.
But let's look at
our performance.
Remember before our performance
was kind of embarrassing?
So now our first meaningful
paint happens at 1.4 seconds.
We were six or seven
seconds last time.
Timed interactive went
from seven seconds,
it was like 7,065 milliseconds,
to 2,100 milliseconds.
Our performance significantly
we increased here.
So that's a big part of why
we got that number bump.
The other one is the site
is progressively enhanced.
The page now has
content if I don't
have JavaScript installed.
So I've got a good piece there.
The rest of these things
haven't really changed.
We haven't made any
big changes here,
so I wouldn't expect
any of these to change.
Design is still mobile
friendly, woohoo.
Our performance, we're in
a better place overall.
Now, we could still do better
and we're going to do better.
Next let's add a service worker.
You heard me talk
today earlier about how
you can build your own service
worker, but let's do it.
One thing to remember,
service workers
are a progressive enhancement.
Not all browsers are
going to support that.
But that's OK, because for
browsers that don't support it,
they're not going to
get that little boost
but for browsers
that do, they will.
So even on browsers that
do support service workers,
that service worker
experience isn't
going to do anything
for the first load.
So it's just that one
little bit to remember.
Our app is built using
an app shell model.
And the app shell model,
think of an app shell model
in a similar way as
a native app would
work where you're going to store
all of the key resources needed
for your app that
aren't going to change.
Everything but the
data on the device.
And then you'll go get
the data from the network.
That way you don't have
to transfer everything.
You only have to transfer
a little bit each time.
That means that we can
cache the app shell locally
and we can use runtime caching
strategies for our data
so that we can make requests
for dynamic content.
One of the most important
things to understand
when you're building
any kind of web app,
and want to use
a service worker,
and want to start
to make it better,
is understanding what network
requests get made and how
and what you need
to do with those.
And then DevTools are a
really important place
to have a look at that.
So we need to
configure-- we're going
to use sw-precache
and sw-toolbox,
those are two libraries I
talked about earlier today,
we need to go and use
those to have a look
and see what's going on.
Let's have a look at how
I went from step two,
where we added server-side
rendering to go and add
our service worker.
The first thing I did
was I added to my gulp
build task sw-precache.
And sw-precache is
that thing that's
going to help us
precache our key pieces.
Then I've added a gulp task
called Generate Service Worker.
Really creative name, I know.
So Generate Service Worker
is going to go and build
our service worker
for us, and there's
a couple of things it does.
It does ARC static files,
it does some dynamic files,
and it does some other various
runtime caching strategies.
So the key thing
here is we said,
hey, I want to cache my app
shell, I want to cache my data,
and we're going
to go from there.
Then we need to make one minor
change to our index.html,
we need to register
our service worker.
So if service
worker in navigator,
register service worker.
So now that we have our
service worker in place,
let's run the Lighthouse tests
again and see how this works
and see how it goes.
So it goes, it loads the
page, renders the trace,
loading page again,
rendering, loading, rendering.
So 20, 37, 52.
So just by adding
a service worker,
we've taken that number and
we've bumped it up a bit.
So there's a couple of key
things that have changed here.
First, here's this big one.
As the service
worker, app can load
in flaky and
offline connections.
That's kind of awesome.
Now performance, first
meaningful paint, awesome.
Time to interact,
those are all great.
Now it's important
to actually make sure
that we are serving our app
from the service worker.
You can use the
DevTools to do that.
And the way that I did that
is I opened up the DevTools
and I went over to the network
and I refreshed the page.
So when I refresh the
page, I get the information
in the network panel.
Here's the file
that was requested.
The HTTP response goes
to 200, awesome, OK.
Actually, I guess
it's not awesome.
It's just OK.
What kind of file it was,
who made the request.
And then here, the
size of the file.
Now look at all these
nice, beautiful brackets
that say from service worker.
That's telling us that that
network request didn't go over
the network, we just pulled
it off our local device.
So almost everything came
from our service worker.
That's exactly what we want.
When you're testing your
site and understanding
where are things coming from,
is this going to work offline,
is this going to work if I
don't have anything, open up
your DevTools and have a look.
Where is everything
being served from?
And at the same time,
also, one thing to notice,
look at these response times.
zero milliseconds, one
millisecond, zero, one, one.
Our worst one is
like 17 milliseconds,
that's kind of awesome.
When you think
about performance,
to be able to get
something that fast,
there's no way
you could get that
across the network in anywhere
near that amount of time.
While we're in the
DevTools, I also
want to point out this
application panel.
This is the one that I talked
about a little bit earlier
and said is probably going to
be one of your best friends.
The application panel
is the central place
for debugging everything
to do with service workers
or progressive web apps.
All the stuff that you need
to deal with is in here.
We can confirm our new
service worker is running.
So service-worker.js is there,
and it tells us when it was
received.
This is an older screenshot.
But it tells us-- here's this
really big one, service worker
status, 0, activated
and is running
and there are no errors.
That's a good sign.
There's another really good one
to keep an eye on when you're
in the service worker panel, if
you're looking at your service
workers.
If you refresh the page, and
I'll show this in one sec,
if you want to see if the
service worker has updated,
look at this number here.
That number tells you what the
idea of the service worker is.
So if I reload
the page right now
and the service
worker hasn't changed,
that number will stay the same.
If I reload the page and
I get a new service worker
and it takes control right away,
that number will get bumped up.
So you can always
tell, oh, hey, hang on.
I updated my service
worker, but the old one
is still running because
the number hasn't changed.
That's just one of those
really helpful little bits
that I like.
There's a couple of other
things that you can do in here.
You can go and you can say--
if you check that
check box, Chrome
will put the browser
into offline mode
and won't send any
requests to the network.
Quick, easy way to test offline.
You don't have to shut down your
server or anything like that.
You can just say, hey, offline.
Update on reload is
another helpful one.
And I recommend
checking this check box
when you're doing your
development, because it always
says, hey, go check for a
new service worker always,
and if there is a
new one, just reload.
Just start using
this right away.
And it always puts
the code into--
puts the service worker
in control right away.
So I use that one a lot.
Finally, bypass for network.
This allows us to skip the
service worker's fetch handler
and go straight to the network.
Skip the service worker
fetch, doesn't that kind of
defeat the purpose of
the service worker?
Yes, it does.
But the good thing here is--
say, for example,
you're testing a page
and you change the color,
you change something in CSS
and the color's not changing.
And you can't figure out
why it's not changing.
You're like, I can't--
just banging your
head against the desk.
Go check that bypass for
network and try refreshing.
If the color changes, it
means that your service worker
isn't updated.
It means that you're still
serving stuff from the cache.
So bypass for network just
skips the service worker cache.
Now let's take a look at a
couple of other little things
that we can do to bump that
number up a little bit more.
Sam talked earlier about
using the manifest to tell
the browser how we want to be
shown on the user's home screen
and add ourselves
to the home screen.
So let's go add the
appropriate metadata.
We're going to use the manifest
because that works for Chrome,
that works for Firefox,
it works for Opera,
it will work for Edge, I believe
soon if it doesn't already.
But it doesn't work
for one other browser
that I bet a bunch of
you have on your phones.
If you use Safari,
Safari doesn't recognize
or doesn't read the manifest.
So for that we need to
add a bunch of meta tags.
Let's have a look at what
we need to do for that.
You saw this with Sam earlier.
This is the manifest.
This is one for the
Washington Post.
We're going to add
something very similar,
and we're going to do this.
I have added an image.
The image that I've
added, I've picked the 144
by 144 pixel icon.
If you're only going
to do one icon,
I would recommend that
one or something bigger.
If you're like me,
you don't start
twitching when you see icons
that have been rescaled
and are not pixel perfect.
Some people who are
very designer smart,
and they all look really
fashionable, and really cool,
and wear turtlenecks
and that kind of thing,
will supply lots of
different icon sizes
and they will hand
tweak each one.
Awesome.
Go for it.
I'm too lazy.
So one icon at 144.
I've added a manifest.
So it's got the
name, the short name,
it's got that one
icon, the start URL,
it says, display stand
alone so that the app always
starts without the address
bar, we set the background
color and a theme color.
Now we've got our manifest.
There's one other thing
that we need to do.
We need to update
our index.html file.
And we need to add
the Apple meta tags.
So we need to do the icon,
the Apple touch icon,
we need to do the Apple
mobile web app capable.
I always hate typing that one
in, it's so long and annoying.
But Apple mobile web
app capable, yes.
And then we need
to tell the browser
about our manifest file.
So that's the one right
there in the middle.
Link rel manifest and
point to our manifest.
So we've added her meta
tags, let's give it a shot.
Let's see how it works.
So go load it in Lighthouse.
It goes and does its thing.
Waiting for page, waiting
for the onload event,
checking HTTPS, and viewport,
theme color, and manifest,
and all that kind of fun stuff.
Normally if you're doing
this on a good, fast network
connection, it will only
take about 15 seconds to run.
If you are doing it like me
at the hotel I'm staying at,
which has not very fast wireless
or a very fast internet,
it takes 30, 45 seconds.
We're almost done here.
Retrieving web SQL, well,
there's really nothing.
78.
That's not bad.
We took our number from
somewhere in the 20s,
to somewhere in the 30s,
to somewhere in the 50s,
to somewhere in the 70s.
That's a little bit better.
We took that number up
pretty significantly
by just adding four things.
The key thing that
we've added here
is we now have that
registered service worker.
So we've got that one bit so
our URL responds with a service
worker and we get a 200 OK
when the app isn't working.
Then there's one other
panel that I like
within the application panel.
And that's a couple
other things.
Looking at this manifest
tab, we can actually
see what's going on
in our manifests.
So we can understand, oh,
hey, we've got these things.
You can see the name
and the short name,
so we can make sure
that the manifest is
being loaded properly.
We can see the start URL, the
theme color, the background
color, the orientation
display, and all of the icons.
One of the things I've
caught, some mistakes
that I've seen in
some of my own apps,
I'll always scroll down
and look at all the icons
because sometimes I've
had a typo in my icon list
and I'll get a broken image.
So just making sure
that all the icons get
loaded, making sure that
you've got everything there.
One of the other
things you can do
is hit that Add to Home
Screen, and that will simulate
adding it to the home screen.
So you can see how
that process will
work because there's a
couple APIs you can throw in
for there.
I can see the
service worker stuff.
Great.
Awesome.
We can see that I took
this at 9:34 last night,
I was working on this.
You can see that
number is up to 12.
I can dig in to the cache.
I can see what's going on
and what's been cached.
In this particular
case, remember
I talked about cache names?
I've got three different
cache names going,
three different cachers,
sw-precache v2 at something,
$$$toolboxcache cache
something, and image cache http.
So you can see all of the
stuff that's in my cache,
I can go, yep, all
those are looking good.
Sweet.
So those tools are really
useful in order to do this.
Now, I am gonna cheat.
I said I wasn't going
to do anything live.
And I'm not really going
to do anything live,
but I'm going to do
something a little live.
I want my screen back, please.
I want to point out one
thing, network is totally off.
There's nothing plugged in here.
You can see all the
fun places I've gone.
Local, host, 8084, which
is where I had my site.
It helps if I'm doing
it in the right browser
and the right person.
There we go, person one.
Let's try this.
8084.
So no network connection.
Everything is there in cache.
And in fact, I can even go in
and see some of these things
that I clicked on earlier.
So I've got that full
experience that works
offline, nice and fast, nice
and easy, works really well.
Let me hop back to my slides.
As you think about
what you're building
and how you're going
through all of your products
and building user
experiences, think about how
you can take tools
like this to say,
how do I make my app better?
What are some easy
things that I can
do to take my app
to the next step?
You don't always have to
start from the beginning.
You don't always have
to do anything crazy.
Just taking little steps is
a really important process.
So I hope I've inspired
you a little bit
to follow our lead to
take some of these things
back to your team, how you
can use Lighthouse as a way
to really understand what's
going on, to build experiences
that delight your users.
But don't forget, progressive,
fast, delightful UX
is your goal.
Building progressive web
apps that are reliable, fast,
and engaging is fun, I
think, and helps us make
the web a little bit better.
Before we go, I'll point
out a couple of links.
The sample code that I showed
you is there at this link,
it's up on GitHub.
You can download
that, you can actually
walk through all the steps,
you can get Lighthouse.
Lighthouse is up
on GitHub as well.
You can either
download the source
and go and compile
it yourself and do
some of the fun,
crazy stuff, look
at how some of the tools
or the tests are written.
You can take a look at a
couple of other things.
But the other one that
we have, and I really
would recommend you
go check this out,
is the code labs that we have on
building progressive web apps.
There's a couple of them,
there's three of them
that I think are
really fantastic.
They're up on developers.googl
e.cn/web/fundamentals/
something, something,
codelabs/, go from there.
Just click that link.
Well, don't click that
link because that's not
going to do anything.
But type that link
into your browser.
The three that are there,
building progressive web
apps from the ground up,
debugging service workers,
which will walk you through
all of that panel really well.
And the third one is
adding push messages
to your progressive web app.
So you can see how that works.
With that, I want to
say, thank you very much.
I've had a great time today.
I hope that you've
learned something as well.
I will open it up
to questions now.
You had questions all day and
now you have no questions?
I'm going to go
sulk in the corner.
Oh, yes!
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I want to ask if
for many websites
they use service workers.
So in the browser, the service
workers were stored many,
I want to ask, is
there cache limitation?
So when their cache
is full, so how
do the browser to [INAUDIBLE]?
SPEAKER: Awesome.
Great question.
Are there many sites using
service workers today?
And then, at some point, as more
sites start using the cache,
the cache is going to
get more and more full.
And at some point, your
phone, your laptop,
might run out of space.
And that could be
a challenge, right?
So there is one place that
I would recommend you go
if you've got Chrome installed.
In the address bar, type
chrome://serviceworker
internals.
That will actually show you
all of the service workers
that are installed on your
device, on your computer.
I'm not sure I'm
going to be brave.
I'm going to try.
Let me just see what
it looks like on--
can we switch to
my laptop again?
Please don't make fun of the
websites that I visit, OK?
That's all I ask.
This is my personal computer.
Well, this is my
personal profile.
Us
You can actually
see all the sites
that I've been to that
have service workers.
I haven't been to many pages.
On my real computer
that I have at home
this goes much, much longer.
So the question about getting--
at some point, you
might start filling out.
There are two things
that are going to happen.
One, there is a new API
called Persistent Storage that
lets you as the web
app developer say,
I want persistent
storage, I want
to be able to keep this
on the user's device
no matter what for
all time, until
the user makes the explicit
decision to blow it away.
That's common.
Actually, that's already
landed in Chrome.
It's coming to other browsers.
For other things,
what's going to happen
is that the browser is
going to blow it away
as it starts to need more
space using a least recently
used algorithm.
So it's going to look
at that one website
that you went to 12 months ago
and haven't been back to since,
and they're taking
out 10 megabytes,
and you haven't been there, so
you're probably not going back.
So it's going to work
through things that way.
It's also not going to go
take up all your hard drive.
Chrome is going to take care
of being a responsible citizen.
As developers, I would
ask you, until we
get more of the
persistence storage stuff,
to be responsible developers.
Don't necessarily download
your entire website
or gigabytes worth of
stuff, because, one, it
will take forever
to install, and two,
the user's not gonna use it.
Don't pull it down.
Next question?
I can sing.
I can't sing.
It's not worth it.
Ask questions or I'm
going to start singing.
OK.
Well then I'm just going to go
to the corner and sulk then.
Thank you all very much.
It's been wonderful.
I hope you enjoyed this.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]